I've never had an experience where
I
met somebody and felt an immediate
depth of relationship to them Austin
Butler reflects on his strong connection
to Lisa Marie Presley I'm just so proud
of it all you know I'm here to support
Austin and baz and film and I'm so
excited and I hope he wins on Monday the
Elvis star opened up about his
friendship with the late
singer-songwriter on The Tonight Show
she was a person who didn't really
have anything to prove and and wouldn't
open up to everybody and she just opened
up to me and we we got so close so fast
um so it's just devastating
[Music]
the two first met during a screening of
the baslerman film at Graceland where
Austin says Lisa Marie took him on a
tour of the iconic estate and brought
him to see her late dad slippers I get
goosebumps his bedroom is a place that
most people never get to see and and she
said you know I wanna I wanna show you
something and she took me up there and
it was it was you know I mean moments
like that we just sat in his bedroom and
up there he's not Elvis He was just dead
you know and so to hear those stories
and
um my I truly will treasure that forever
all Austin stars as Elvis in the biopic
he's received critical Acclaim across
the board including a nomination at the
upcoming Oscars
came to the right place his portrayal of
the king of rock and roll also earned
him a Golden Globe the presidents who
welcome me into their
way and I just feel so endlessly
grateful to them that they
provided this space for me to somehow
try to capture the essence of this man
that they've that means so much to them
and that they love so much but Austin
says the whole thing is now Bittersweet
following the sudden death of Lisa Marie
so much great stuff is happening but
it's really
um I'm just you know devastated for a
family and sure for her to not be here
celebrating with us Lisa Marie died
earlier this month after suffering a
cardiac arrest just two days after
attending the Golden Globes what was it
like watching Austin on stage and during
this movie in the making of this movie
it was mind-blowing truly mind-blowing I
really didn't know what what to do with
myself after after I saw it yeah I had
to take like five days to process it
because it was so incredible and so spot
on
and so authentic Austin was one of many
who attended Lisa Marie's Memorial at
Graceland which was live streamed from
the front lawn of the Memphis estate and
now Austin says he'll cherish those
final moments he had with her to get to
be with her at the Golden Globes like
I'll never forget that for the rest of
my life
[Music]